Trabajemos con este problema que tiene que ver
con funciones exponenciales, dice,
Liam abre una cuenta de ahorros en donde deposita 6250 pesos.
6250 pesos esto va a ser importante.
Cada año su cuenta crece un 20%,
cada año su cuenta crece un 20%.
¿Cuántos años se necesitarán
para obtener una cuenta con 12960 pesos?
Escribe una ecuación que modele la situación.
Usa "t" para representar el número de años
desde que Liam abre la cuenta.
Y bueno, me gustaría que tú intentaras
resolver este problema por ti mismo,
así que es buen momento para que pauses este video
e intente resolverlo.
Así vas a ver si llegamos a la misma respuesta.
Así que pausa el video
y voy a empezar a resolver lo justo ahorita.
Ok,
eh, vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con Liam.
En un primer año...
y déjame ponerlo con este color...
Si nosotros empezamos en el año 0,
justo en el momento en el que Liam día abre la cuenta,
bueno, pues Liam tiene 6250 pesos,
entonces lo voy a poner aquí
empezó con 6250 pesos, de lujo.
Ahora, después de que pase un año,
en el año 1,
Liam ya no va a tener solamente 6250 pesos,
va a tener estos mismos 6250 pesos pero además
fíjate que esta cuenta crece con un 20%,
es decir, va a tener más 20%
de estos a 6250 pesos...
déjame ponerlo con este color...
de estos mismos 6250 pesos.
Ahora, quiero que te des cuenta,
que esto podemos escribirlo de la siguiente manera,
esto es exactamente lo mismo,
si yo factorizo precisamente este 6250
va a quedar, 6250
que multiplica...
bueno, en primer lugar a 1,
va a multiplicar a 1,
que es sí mismo, este de aquí,
va a multiplicar a 1
y después va a multiplicar al 20%.
Ahora recuerda que el 20%,
lo podemos escribir como el 0.20,
el 0.20 visto en su forma decimal.
Y es que esto se me facilita mucho más
porque ahora puedo escribir esta misma ecuación
esta misma igualdad como 6250
que multiplica a 1.2...
ok...
Va a multiplicar a esta cantidad
o a este valor de aquí.
Ahora vamos a pensar
qué es lo que pasa en el transcurso del segundo año.
Cuando llegamos al final del segundo año,
el dinero de Liam va a volver a cambiar.
y ¿cómo va a volver a cambiar?
bueno, pues esencialmente lo que va a pasar,
es que vamos a tener la misma cantidad
que nosotros ganamos en el primer año,
esta cantidad de aquí, es decir  "A1"
y la vamos a multiplicar otra vez por 1.2,
que es la tasa de crecimiento,
a esto lo vamos a multiplicar por 1.2...
por 1.2...
Y bueno, esto nos va a quedar,
esto va a ser exactamente lo mismo, que 6250...
que 6250,
que a su vez multiplica a 1.2,
a este 1.2,
que sube multiplica a 1.2,
y bueno, esto lo podemos escribir,
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 6250...
que 6.250 que multiplica a 1.2,
que multiplica a 1.2 elevado al cuadrado,
1.2 por 1.2,
es 1.2 elevado al cuadrado.
Ahora, ya te puedes imaginar qué es lo que pasa
después de que transcurra el tercer año,
en el año 3,
bueno, pues creo que
ya te puedes dar cuenta del patrón.
Cuando transcurra el tercer año, lo que va a pasar
es que vamos a seguir teniendo 6250 pesos,
pero ahora lo voy vamos a multiplicar por 1.2...
por 1.2...
elevado al cubo...
al cubo porque estamos en el tercer año.
Entonces ya podemos generalizar,
ya podemos pensar,
qué es lo que va a pasar en el año "t".
como queremos saber cuántos años
y vamos a usar "t" para representar ese número de años,
en el año "t",
nosotros sabemos que esto va a ser igual
a 6250,
por 1.2,
estamos siguiendo el patrón,
elevado a la "t"...
elevado a la "t",
que es, la cantidad de años.
Ahora, esta es la típica fórmula
del interés compuesto,
sin embargo, en esta ocasión tenemos,
hasta qué cantidad queremos llegar,
queremos obtener 12960 pesos
por lo tanto, lo que quiero,
es que esta cantidad que estamos poniendo justo aquí,
sea igual a 12960 pesos...
a 12960 pesos...
o dicho de otra manera, y si escribimos bien la ecuación,
me va a quedar que 12960 pesos,
esto tiene que ser igual...
tiene que ser igual a 6250,
a 6250,
Ok, que multiplica...
que multiplica a 1.2,
que multiplica a 1.2 elevado a la "t"
y justo lo que queremos saber,
es la cantidad de años, es decir, "t",
a "t", ok...
Ahora estas ecuaciones de aquí,
son ecuaciones exponenciales
y se le conocen como ecuaciones exponenciales,
porque lo que nosotros buscamos está en el exponente,
de hecho, está justo aquí.
Y bueno,
hay varias formas de resolver ecuaciones exponenciales,
y sería muy bueno que tú aprendieras bien,
cómo responderlas.
Ahora, lo que se me ocurre en primer lugar,
es pasar este 6250 del otro lado dividiendo.
Para que me quede solamente lo que tiene que ver con la potencia del lado derecho
y lo voy a poner primero,
me va a quedar,
que 1.2...
1.2 elevado a la "t"
elevado a la "t"
esto es exactamente lo mismo...
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 6250...
déjame cambiar a ese mismo color...
a 12960...
y éste lo voy a pasar del otro lado dividiendo,
es decir, estoy dividiendo todo entre 6250.
y bueno, lo padre de esto es que 6250
y éste son divisibles entre 10,
así que vamos a quitar estos ceros de una vez,
que nos estorban.
Este 0 no lo quiero por ahorita,
ok,
y este 0 tampoco lo quiero por ahorita.
Entonces, me voy a quedar solamente
con esta expresión que tengo aquí.
"1.2t" es igual a 1296 entre 625,
para no confundirnos voy a quitar también esta coma
y la voy a poner justo aquí,
ok, es una coma que está aquí...
Muy bien y ¿cuánto es esto?
Pues, qué te parece si sacamos la calculadora
y vemos
cómo podemos resolver esta ecuación.
Lo primero que quiero saber es cuánto es 1296...
1296 entre 625,
así que vamos a traer la calculadora,
que la tengo justo por aquí,
y con esta, vamos a poder ayudarnos
a resolver este problema.
Cuánto es 1296 entre...
¡Oh! ¿dónde está el entre?
entre 625.
Bueno, esto es lo mismo que 2.0736.
Ok,
yo lo que quiero es elevar 1.2
a una cierta cantidad de años,
y que me de 2.0736
Y bueno, para resolver
este tipo de ecuaciones exponenciales,
hay varias formas de hacerlo,
sin embargo, quiero que en una primera instancia
lo hagamos, de una manera muy intuitiva,
si yo lo que quiero es encontrar el valor de "t",
qué te parece si multiplicamos 1.2,
por sí mismo cuantas veces sea necesario,
hasta que lleguemos a este valor de aquí,
así que voy a multiplicar esto por 1.2
y me da, ok,
1.44
todavía no llegamos,
a ver 1.2 por... por... no, este es el menos,
vamos a borrar...
por 1.2
por ésta aquí
1.2 esto me da,
1.728,
a ver otra vez...
1.2 por
1.2
por 1.2
por 1.2,
si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 4 veces,
¡de lujo!
es justo lo que yo quería llegar a 2.0736
es este mismo valor,
por lo tanto,
1.2 por 1.2 por 1.2 por 1.2,
es decir, 1.2 elevado a la cuarta potencia
es justo el resultado que yo quiero
y ahora lo puedo escribir aquí.
Déjame borrar este punto,
y voy a poner entonces que "t"
la cantidad de años que yo quiero,
es igual a 4,
que es lo mismo que,
1.2 por 1.2 por 1.2 por 1.2
Ok, bueno, esta es una forma de resolverlo,
ahora, también hay otras formas de resolverlo,
déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla para que lo veas.
La siguiente forma que quiero que veamos,
de cómo se resuelve este tipo de problemas,
ok bajemos la pantalla...
es pensar en cómo podemos ver a 1.2,
que se parezca a esta expresión de aquí,
y bueno, es que 1.2,
lo podemos ver como seis quintos,
esto sería lo mismo...
déjame ponerlo con este color...
que 6 sobre 5...
sobre 5...
elevado a la "t"...
elevado a la "t"
y es que aquí me acabo de dar cuenta,
que la potencia de abajo tiene que ver...
tiene que ver con el 5,
¿625 cuánto es?
bueno, pues déjeme cambiar de color...
si yo saco el 625,
5 por 5 es lo mismo que 25, ok,
25 por 5 es lo mismo que 125
y es que me acabo de dar cuenta que,
125 por 5,
es lo mismo que 625,
o sea que esta expresión de aquí,
la puedo ver exactamente igual como,
6...
como 6 elevado a una cierta potencia,
entre 5 elevado...
entre 5 elevado a la cuarta potencia...
elevado a la cuarta potencia...
¡y qué crees!
1296 que es lo mismo que
6 elevado a la cuarta potencia
y justo en este momento puedo decir que,
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 6...
déjame ponerlo con este color...
que 6 sobre 5, ok,
que 6 sobre 5...
sobre 5...
todo esto...
todo esto, elevado a la cuarta potencia...
elevado a la cuarta potencia
y bueno si tengo 6 sobre 5 elevado a la "t",
es lo mismo que 6 sobre 5 elevado a la cuarta potencia
entonces "t" tiene que ser igual a 4
y deduzco,
ya van dos veces que llegó a la misma respuesta.
Déjame ponerlo con mucho cuidado,
"t" tiene que ser igual a 4
aquí otra forma de resolver
este tipo de ecuaciones exponenciales.
Ahora se me ocurre que hay otra forma infalible
de resolver este tipo de ecuaciones exponenciales.
En este caso me salió que
"t" es un número exacto,
sin embargo, no siempre debe de ser un número exacto
en una ecuación exponencial,
Por lo tanto, la forma infalible, en la cual
siempre sale la respuesta de este tipo de problemas,
es la siguiente.
Lo que voy a hacer es sacar la calculadora,
y de hecho,
ya hemos probado en varios vídeos sobre logaritmos, esto que voy a utilizar.
Lo que voy a utilizar es
sacar el logaritmo en base 10.
Y lo que voy a hacer es, sacar el logaritmo en base 10,
de ambos lados de esta ecuación.
Y es que entonces el consejo que te doy,
es que para sacar el logaritmo en base 10
y saber la solución de este problema,
tenemos que hacer lo siguiente,
poner el logaritmo en base 10,
¿de quién? bueno, tenemos esta división
1, 2, 9, 6
que a su vez divide a
625, ok...
es esta parte derecha...
y después, a esto... a esto...
hay que dividirlo entre logaritmo en base 10,
de la base que tiene el exponente,
es decir 1.2...
1.2...
y en varios vídeos de Khan Academy,
he visto, justo esto.
Esto nos sirve para resolver
cualquier tipo de ecuación exponencial
y si yo le pongo enter me da, ¡4!
¡Exacto! que es justo nuestro resultado.
Si pongo ahora la calculadora para acá,
me acaba de decir de nuevo, la calculadora,
de una tercer manera,
cómo podemos encontrar,
la solución de este tipo de problemas,
utilizando el logaritmo en base 10.
Y bueno,
déjame ponértelo otra vez por aquí,
porque tal vez esto parece un poco de vudú o algo muy raro,
pero está impresionante
y tú te lo puedes aprender así,
para poder resolver cualquier tipo de ecuación exponencial.
Lo único que hice fue tomarme el lado derecho, ok,
la parte que no tiene que ver con el exponente,
y puse el logaritmo en base 10,
de la parte que está en el lado derecho.
De igual manera pude haber puesto logaritmo
en base 10 de 2.0736, que era la división de estos dos.
Ok, y a eso lo dividí
y aquí está el gran consejo que te doy,
hay que dividirlo entre el logaritmo en base de 10,
de la base que tiene el exponente de 1.2.
Y entonces, vamos a llegar,
al resultado que nosotros queremos,
es resultados 4.
Y bueno, en este caso 4,
es un número bastante buena onda.
pero nosotros podríamos tener 3.9,
3.725,
o cualquier loquera
y con esta forma de resolver ecuaciones exponenciales,
siempre vamos a llegar al resultado.